what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight plot league video today I'm going
to be reading another plot leak that was
sent to me via email as you all know I
always get a kick out of reading these
even if they are fanfiction which most
of them are I have read several
different variations on this channel
already but I continue to get sent new
ones almost every week most of them I
delete immediately because they are just
so inconsistent without season 7 ended
it just wouldn't make much sense for any
of it to happen but sometimes I get sent
ones that do line up with some of the
things I expect to see next season let
me make this clear though that doesn't
mean that I like them
I thought about reading the whole thing
in one video but it would take a while
because this one is fairly detailed so I
figured I would read the first episode
here and if enough of you want me to
read the rest I will only if I get
enough people saying they want to hear
more though but if most of you think
this is trash then I won't bother
spending any more time making videos on
this according to the person that posted
this leaked he said he works on the set
of Game of Thrones personally I do not
believe him
but what the hell I will give it a shot
anyway just in case he basically said he
has seen enough while working there to
know almost everything that will happen
next season so he took notes and posted
them on Reddit typically I would call
[ __ ] right away but last year a way
for the lads said something very similar
and he just happened to be telling the
truth
so I guess there is always a chance for
these kind of things to happen but well
lightning strike twice and back-to-back
seasons probably not but let's proceed
anyways season 8 episode 1 the opening
scene is at Castle black
berrak and torment warned ed of the
breakthrough at eastwatch-by-the-sea
from the night Kings dragon Edie begins
to prepare Ravens to warn everyone but
then he hears the sound of a horn the
horn sounds three times in the army of
the Dead are seen approaching from the
southeast
berrak tells torment to head south while
barrack stays with Lord Commander ed
barrack says he still has a purpose to
serve he pulls out his sword and it
ignites
the Ravens take flight and are heading
south until the dragon appears and
unleashes its blue flame on them berrak
shouts that not all the dead are coming
to Castle black a larger army is seen
following the night king and Viserion
that are heading further south the
whites reach Castle black in the battle
begins the next scene is bran in the
godswood at the weirwood tree he asks
the maester how long he has been in his
vision the maester says a few hours
bran notes that he has not seen anything
this time he says that he may have been
thrown out of a vision and something
must be wrong
John Daenerys Jorah Tyrion Varys Brienne
the hound in some soldiers ride to the
gate at Winterfell several guards of the
north greet them at the gate they look
at Daenerys suspiciously Jorah notices
this and he looks worried Shonda and
Arya arrive at the gate and Sansa looks
at Daenerys suspiciously as well and
Tyrion notices that they are reinforcing
the walls
Sansa greets John and she asks him how
he managed to bring Daenerys and Cersei
to peace John hugs her and he says it's
not that easy
John hugs Arya and says so you did stick
them with the pointy end Arya smiles
she is very pleased to see John again
John and Brian look at each other and
John looks very worried Sam Gilly and
the baby are looking from across the
yard ghost is next to Sam at this time
Sansa tells John that brain situation is
hard to explain
Sansa says brain has visions Brian asks
Sansa where Littlefinger is John wants
to know that as well so he repeats the
question
Arya answers John quite relaxed and says
that she executed him John looks
concerned then Sam greets him John bends
down to greet ghost and he brushes his
fur for a few moments John and Sam began
to talk about their time apart and Sam
asks John about the dragon glass on
Dragonstone John also says that so far
Longclaw has never failed him against
the White Walkers tyrion addresses songs
oh and he
sir how she escaped King's Landing after
Joffrey's death Sansa says Littlefinger
was behind everything John asks Sansa
why Winterfell was being prepared for
his siege
Sansa says a friend once told me you
should prepare for any scenario then we
will not experience any surprises then
she smiles and Jon seems impressed Jon
then tells everyone to gather in the
main hall in the hall John tells
everyone that the king in the north is
now serving Queen Daenerys Targaryen
angry shouts erupted in the hall in
Sansa look shocked
Lord Royce angrily asks Jon why he
hasn't learned from the mistakes of
Brandon Stark and his father Targaryen
cannot be trusted John explains that he
is obviously still alive John also says
Daenerys has not only provided
dragonglass
but she has also provided her armies and
her dragons
he says she has already helped him fight
the dead despite the dangerous threat
she has also sacrificed one of her
dragons which she considered a child of
hers lord glover then says he did not
see any of this for himself
Daenerys explains that she did not come
to conquer them Lyanna Mormont then
asked Danny about the peace treaty with
Cersei Daenerys says the war is at a
momentary standstill the war will
continue after the night King is
defeated turmoil rises again an aria
says aloud we cannot trust Cersei
Lannister she lied to stay alive I do
not believe she will stay at peace Jorah
Mormont begins to get nervous and he
grabs the hilt of his sword in the side
corridor sam asks bran when he plans on
telling john the truth brain says right
now is not the right time the tensions
are already too high what Daenerys being
here John says he will not force anyone
to stay in the north and fight and he
also says he will go to war for Daenerys
as she has already done the same for him
Lord Royce as Tyrion if his sister
Cersei can be trusted Tyrion says they
can because Cersei is aware of the
threat of the army of the dead John says
there is no time to think about that
everyone needs to send all of their men
north Lyanna Mormont and Lord Manderly
agree Daenerys says the dead do not
argue they follow their king and they
are coming she has seen it herself brian
says Daenerys is right the dead do not
speak they follow one King the night
King I know many of you do not believe
what I can see but I have seen him I met
him first in a vision then he found me
beyond the wall he's coming he's always
coming and he's getting closer they have
to stop him now
Daenerys tells the other lords they need
to fight together and trust each other
in the next scene
Qyburn enters Circe's chambers he tells
her the next phase is near completion in
your grace should see it for herself
they then walk through the Great Hall
and they enter a back room with a
trapdoor they go down a ladder in they
enter a seller that's pitch black except
there is a faint glow in the back of the
room when they enter Cersei sees there
is hundreds of pots of wildfire stored
right under the throne room in Qyburn
says there's more still stashed around
the city in the next senior on arrives
in Essos Euron meets with the commander
of the golden company and he begins to
mock them because of their pretty golden
uniforms in their decorated elephants
the men of the golden company begin to
board your own ships along with war
horses and elephants the commander then
asks your on if it's true does this
Targaryen Queen really have dragons
Euron says yes Daenerys does have
dragons but we also have something to
defeat them he then uncovers a large
weapon at the back of his ship the
commander does not seem impressed
Euron then asks him if the golden
company has Knights exiled from Westeros
the commander says yes and Euron says
good that makes us brothers I was exiled
- Jaime meets with Bronn a few miles
outside of the city he tells Bronn he is
leaving King's Landing and leaving
Cersei for good he says he plans on
keeping his word - Jon and Daenerys and
if bran intends on surviving the winter
and ever getting paid he should come
with him bran is not
to hear this but Heba grudgingly agrees
to help John is then seen in the crypts
of Winterfell with Daenerys and she
asked John how many family members has
he lost in the recent Wars John talks
about Ned and Catelyn and Robb and
Rickon
he says Rickon died right in front of
him during the battle for Winterfell
John says Robb was betrayed
unfortunately his own mistakes led to
his death John says a broken promise
cost him his life Robb was set to Wed
but he chose another woman instead and
it got him killed
John looks at Ned statue and Daenerys
does the same but then Daenerys looks at
Liana's and asks John who she is John
says that's my aunt Lyanna she was
abducted by Rhaegar Targaryen it
ultimately triggered Robert's rebellion
Daenerys seems confused by this she says
I have heard many things about my
brother Rhaegar but it was always good
things in abduction of a defenseless
woman does not sound like him John looks
at Liana and then Daenerys he says it
doesn't matter now they are all dead and
there is nothing we can do to change
that in the next scene Tyrion is then
seen alone in a room writing someone a
letter who he is writing is not revealed
torment arrives at Winterfell is gate
his horse is ready to collapse as Jon
and Daenerys are exiting the crypts they
both noticed the guards are in a frenzy
they see them talking to torment and he
seems to be distressed torment tells Jon
what happened at eastwatch-by-the-sea in
Castle black
he says the night king has the dragon
and he's coming their way
Jon is utterly shocked in Daenerys is on
the verge of tears in the next scene we
are at the last hearth and there is a
small boy seen outside playing in the
snow with his father suddenly the boy
stops and his father asks him what's
wrong the boy points to the nearby tree
line there are hundreds or more of blue
eyes peering through the trees the man
tells his son to get inside now the
whites begin running into the village
and horns begin to blow in little Ned
umber comes outside was several soldiers
at his side as more soldiers come
outside the south
of a dragon quickly drowns out the horns
that were blowing they tell Ned umber to
get back inside but it's too late there
are too many thousands of whites led by
multiple White Walkers and Giants are
now just a hundred feet away the night
King comes out of the storm and Viserion
begins to unleash his blue flame on Thor
Castle chaos erupts and everyone begins
to get butchered vissarion's blue flame
delivers a devastating blow to the
umbers ancestral home Ned umbers
personal guard has slaughtered leaving
him all alone one of the White Walkers
approaches him and with one swift move
he Pierce's his heart with his ice sword
Ned umber falls to the ground as his
home and people are destroyed the final
shot of the episode shows nearly a dozen
white walkers walking across the
blood-soaked battlefield every man woman
and child lay slain at their feet the
night King then lands Viserion and he
steps off him for a moment the camera
will then pan across the ground showing
all the bodies begin to twitch and move
until it shows that umber his eyes begin
to open with a piercing blue color in
the episode ends alrighty then folks
this is season 8 episode 1 put all your
thoughts or questions down below in the
comment section what did you love what
did you hate if any let me know if you
want me to read the rest of the episodes
or not I will leave that up to you
either way I want to thank you for
taking the time to watch the video
hopefully you were entertained even if
you think it's fake I also want to thank
everyone on patreon who continues to
support the channel made of faith of the
seven the Lord of Light and the old gods
and the new
bless you all have a great day everyone
I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you